[Music]
zara baha'i is something of a pioneer in
afghanistan she comes from mazari sharif
in the north of the country where she
was a beekeeper a school teacher and the
head of the local city council
but what she's most known for in
afghanistan is being the country's first
woman to drive a taxi
in sarah's home country it's seen as
shocking for a woman to get behind the
wheel
named
sarah started driving a taxi so she
could support her family as her income
as a teacher wasn't enough
after getting her driving license she
helps women and girls in her village
feel safe
as sarah's fame grew she was accepted in
the community she even created a driving
course solely for women learners and
trained five women as taxi drivers
but in 2021 she had to flee afghanistan
after the taliban returned to power
women's rights have been eroded even
further under taliban rule and sarah's
life was in danger
she managed to escape to europe where
she's now settled in portugal but her
family is still in afghanistan and she's
hoping that they'll be able to join her
against
[Music]
for years the european parliament has
stood up for women's rights in
afghanistan
the mep nacho census amor was one of the
people to bring her case to the
attention of eu authorities
in 2021 the parliament nominated a
collective of 11 afghan women for the
sakharov prize for freedom of thought to
honour their brave fight for equality
and human rights
[Music]
you